what's up tasty
my name is max the meat guy and this is
a story of how i got gordon ramsay to
react to me on tiktok
[Music]
i've always had a huge passion for
cooking and knew that one day i wanted
to make food related content
one night after having a few drinks i
decided tomorrow's the day
i had no idea what i was going to post
but i was going for it i started a
tik-tok account and really i was just
throwing stuff against the wall i made a
peanut butter and jelly ribs
energy drink chicken i was recreating
things like cinnamon toast crunch just
totally random stuff these videos
weren't really clicking you know i
didn't
have my personal voice yet and that's
really what i was looking for so the
first video that really started taking
off was the prime rib laced with bacon
check out that marbling start with the
cut from the chuck end the prized cap
muscle is the thickest traditional prime
rib has a great crust but a bland
interior opening it up we increase the
surface area and get perfectly seasoned
and crispy bites
all throughout whip out the flame
thrower and let's go to work
salt pepper maple bacon
wrap up your present now let's tie her
up
compound butter is where it's at two
sticks garlic shallots
herbs and of course steak rub it looks
like a lot of butter that's because it
is let's take it to the grill
we're cooking with cherry wood low and
slow
save those juices
thick crust on the outside perfect
medium air on the inside
laced with pockets of bacon so this is
the first video that i really felt
was true to myself and it was taking you
know a traditional
amazing dish and trying to find a way to
push the boundaries and put my own spin
on it so after the prime rib
i hit a hundred thousand followers and
wanted to do something crazy with wings
so i did a hundred thousand scoville
unit smoked
and deep fried hot chicken wings
[Music]
get the party started with some clean
applewood smoke baby raisin franks
time to get spicy cayenne ancho chili's
fresh jalapeno
habanero boasting over a hundred
thousand scoville units of heat
if you know you know candied bacon on
chicken wings
yup mix it up and let's check on those
wings
oil bacon fat fry no more leathery
chicken skin this is crispy city
toss ranch plate bacon
liftoff so the wing video did really
well
but i wanted to do something crazy and
at that time there was a tick tock trend
going around called ramsay reacts where
gordon ramsay was reviewing
tick tock videos and i knew that one of
his favorite dishes
is the beef wellington so i decided to
put my spin on it
and show him something that i think he'd
get a kick out of
kielbasa the glizzy king smoked over
applewood
put the work in on those mushrooms
let them soften and add your time now we
assemble
parma ham mushroom
glizzy
lay out that puff pastry and it's time
to paint with that egg yolk
wrap up your present
pretend you're gordon ramsay and here we
go
a golden crust welcomes glizzy goodness
to the world
much to my surprise ramsay reacted but i
will say
it was not entirely positive he called
me a donut called me a sausage man but
truthfully i was just honored that one
of my idols watched one of my videos
got some new eyes on my account and i
really wanted to keep that momentum
going forward
so i decided to take a risk and make a
recipe that was absolutely
bombarded with flavor the smoked salmon
cinnamon bun
this is a whole side of salmon and we're
taking it to the next level
brine overnight and make your filling
cream cheese jalapeno
lemon dill capers barbecue rub
season lightly and add your filling
[Music]
wrap up your present cut
thick slices and admire your cinnamon
bun
citrus and let's hit the grill don't
forget to make your bed
tuck that salmon in it's nap time smoke
over applewood
and let's make our glaze miso maple and
of course
our candied bacon
glaze and finish with lemon zest
this is a showstopper just ended up
working
so incredibly well and this recipe is
truly something i'm proud of
and i actually just dropped the salmon
cinnamon bun part two
on my youtube so for my next video i
wanted to keep experimenting and how
people perceive
food looking at things like a birthday a
wedding
why not incorporate a recipe that really
takes that to heart
but with meat
this is the steak cake ribeye strip
sirloin season with killer hogs and roll
your bacon roses
season with a sweet rub and get them on
the grill
applewood low and slow time for our
creamy mashed potato
icing back on the grill sear till 1 30
internal
and now we assemble ice the bone in rib
eye and add your second layer top
with blackhawk farms wagyu
and if this isn't what my future wedding
cake looks like i don't want the wedding
and yes everyone gets a slice it turned
out great it tasted phenomenal
and then totally to my surprise again
gordon ramsay reacted to the steak cake
once again he called me a donut he did
say that this cake should be used at a
divorce proceedings and not a wedding
he has a fair point there i believe the
exact comment was
seasoned smart nice hey it's progress
well it has been an absolutely crazy few
months
and i've learned to just take the first
step and if you find a creative outlet
that you enjoy
go down that path as hard as you can and
don't look back
i really hope you enjoyed these recipes
i'd love to hear what you think of them
you can find so many more of them
at max the meat guy and i hope to see
you soon
[Music]
you